otra jornada sin electricidad en Cuba
después del paso del huracán son
hospitales y algunas zonas del país
cuentan con ese servicio en la Habana
tan solo el 10% de los dos millones de
sus habitantes contaban con electricidad
el jueves 48 horas en electricidad y
para poder cargar los teléfonos para
poder tener comunicación gracias a la
empresa nos está haciendo en favor de
poder cargar aquí sin embargo los
capitalinos buscan disímiles maneras de
entretenimiento para mitigar el calor y
esperar el restablecimiento de la
electricidad prácticamente gratis arena
tenemos de todo Estamos refrescando un
poco acá en aquí en cerquita de la casa
en familia todos los vecinos venimos
para acá nos estamos divirtiendo los
niños están viviendo buscando la manera
y disfrutando también las horas del
Malecón otros prefieren expresar su
descontento y exigir la resolución de
los problemas acumulados agravados ahora
por el paso de Ian
la luz les fue restablecida No había
necesidad
a ponernos la electricidad la unión
eléctrica nacional ofrece un parte
diario de la situación que lentamente
avanza posteriormente si hay que hacer
ya los balances de generación carga no
no tenemos como como estaba sucediendo
antes de que ocurriera el paso del
huracán guía no teníamos capacidad en
relación suficiente para cubrir la
demanda eso no ha cambiado el presidente
cubano continúa realizando recorridos
por las zonas más afectadas en esta
ocasión al sur de la capital donde
Incluso se personó en una central de
generación eléctrica que inició su
aporte al Sistema electroenegético
Nacional